president Trump passed his medical exam
with flying colors yeah
Wow that whoa
shilling people find the concept of his
good health yeah exactly
presidents in good health
that's all I said I didn't do anything
yeah yeah after the results of his
physical were released many Americans
are claiming President Trump is lying
about his weight yeah yeah in other
words maybe he really is one of us you
know closer to him right
it's humanizes him doctors are saying
the result of president Trump's physical
revealed that he is borderline obese
yeah yeah in fairness he did promise us
growth so we're good shape right down
here what else going on president Trump
is now claiming his approval rating
among black Americans has doubled yeah
in other words Ben Carson voted twice
let's see yeah I got some good news okay
we could use good news sure we good
relations with North Korea are thawing a
bit North and South Korea getting along
a little better here's the latest North
Korea announced that it will send a
group of citizens called the cheering
squad to next month's Winter Olympics
yeah yeah and many of them are expected
to actually compete in a new event
called the 400-meter defection
[Applause]
got some bride those giggles for a bit
professional racecar driver Danica
Patrick is dating again after breaking
up with her previous boyfriend a NASCAR
driver yeah when asked why that
relationship didn't work out Patrick
explained we were just going in circles
I love that I heard cheering and booing
and the people booing are not wrong I'm
shocked you let me get away with that
you should get your money back
costs a lot to get in here tonight if
you're watching on TV
you